no no they got bonus did we have a
rigorous standing in front he hooks you
into the yo-yo then you take a deep
breath take a big step and then it's up
to ladder just go up normally and you
can start your work up top then always
Stefan shweta can't afford to be afraid
of heights as if you wanna think we
carry the stuff up and then I have to
check something since I it today right
now I'm accompanying the Zeman's team
they're testing everything blade pitch
adjustment cooling water gear oil for
instance they're looking for errors
whether all the switchboards are
communicating with each other actually
probably shouldn't be claustrophobic
there are no windows and you definitely
should not have a fear of heights he has
to climb up 19 meters hospin East's sure
is windy one the Machine cabin sways
there's only a railing that reaches just
above your stomach when you lean over it
you need to have a head for Heights most
valiant so much love even if amazing
far off on Heligoland the tourists
unconcerned by all of that for the
moment Warren some Islanders amulets
there's supposed to be a heliport with
two hangars for two helicopters one
doesn't if I fear inhale and none out in
hotel years he began a lot of Islanders
and hotel owners a worried whatever work
is in an unsafe for anointing it they
fear that the plan nine hundred flights
per year could have a negative effect on
tourism the I'd frozen gun did thus
estas hisses dead guests who come to
heligoland are really looking for the
most common answer is peace and quiet
quiet with a slow pace getting away from
a died issue tonight detlef rickmers
runs the biggest hotel on the island and
he's worried about the islands image he
owns a heligoland institution a
four-star hotel that's been here for
more than 100 years finish panini in w
2000 in the boom years of the 1970s and
80s we had up to 10,000 day-trippers
each day today on busy days it's 2,500
the total number of visitors to
heligoland is at the level of was in
1958 the I can be hidden dusty is yes
the industry is 20 kilometers offshore
but in the public perception people
associate the offshore industry with
heligoland does that's not actually the
case here but what's significant for us
is how it's perceived on the mainland
and the rest of the world and I worry
that the image will prevail that we have
heavy industry here he is
there are three construction fields with
more than 200 turbines owned by several
different energy companies technicians
Stefan Schroeder has to improvise he
lacks important equipment for three
colleagues yeah woman he radios a
colleague to find out where he is and
whether his team has survival bags on
board survival bags contain water and
food for emergencies they're not allowed
to work if they don't have them and
that's lost time let's move south you
move in yet our loss part that's kind
it's simply not allowed you can't go up
in the rig they're very strict and
they're right to be so wasted
next week it's impossible now for anyone
to avoid wind power even the most
stubborn islanders